gentlemen how are you doing
doing good good how are you stevie i'm
doing excellent i'm talking about an
awesome show
uh it's a not a bad day nice
nice uh one of the things listen um i've
seen the first three episodes of season
two
[ __ ] doesn't slow down it it's you know
just continuation of season one
um what what was the i'm very curious
you guys had extra time with season two
to film it you had like extra days in
the shooting schedule can you sort of
talk about what that added
um or what you were able to maybe do
with that extra time
well i think as you've seen in some of
the um
teaser trailers and stuff the general
scope and scale of
uh season two is a lot more ambitious
than season one
uh we had a whole sequence that we shot
on the water
uh we had the entire cast in the
speedboat we had a life-sized
replica a functioning set of a beached
sperm whale
that we were working both inside and
outside of
and you know just generally all around
everything was like
season one except on steroids um
you know and we talked to kripke and our
showrunner eric kripke and the lead up
to it and he goes listen i'm not going
to try and go bigger this season
i'm going to go deeper we're going to
you know rip away
you know the element that's most
precious to every single character and
see how they deal with it and
you know it's going to be character
driven and and you know he totally
achieved that but he also went totally
bigger
so you know that's what we did with our
extra days just more
days covered in blood yeah more days
covered in blood and you know
usually shows save their biggest punch
for the season finale
and i feel like we have at least three
episodes
that are scale and scope of a season
finale worthy
episode you know so that's how much
bigger
we went this season you know but in
spite of going deeper
we also went bigger i think i i felt
that about like reading
um episode three i mean it was episode
three and we have this whole
sequence where you know we have the
whale and the boat i'm like how
are we gonna top this and um you know to
full credit to uh again to kripke and
the writers because
as the season wears on it just gets
more and more intense and more shocking
as you would expect from the boys
one one of the things is that there is
specifically episode three i'm not going
to spoil anything but
there's an awful lot of blood just
an awful lot and it's not the kind of
blood that like
it's just so all over everybody
um what is it like being on set when you
have to be covered like that for like
that's just not an afternoon that's days
of being covered in blood
that was 14 days that was 14 i mean
there were days where
the the blooding took two hours
and then however many hours that we
worked they're constantly retouching us
up and adding blood
uh and then they have to also blood up
bloody up our clothes
and our shoes and our socks because
everything has to match
so in essence after you get bloody
then you're putting on a wet bloody
clothes and that literally
will creep into every crevice and core
that you did not know existed on your
body i discovered
places where blood could creep too
no joke i i uh ended up billing the
production for 14 pairs of white kelvins
that were
wrecked with artificial blood
you wear calvin's to set bro absolutely
man i need to get on your pay scale come
on
you heard it here folks these are
spoilers
you sort of feel like with episode three
and whatever else happens in the season
that you've
sort of made your evil dead movie but
it's just called the boys
yeah you know uh you know just when you
think that
uh this show can't get any more dial
can you get a new script and you know
uh it takes it to the next level
and um you know i uh
i think we're all um pretty proud of
season two and we can't wait for
it to reach an audience and i have no
idea
how they're going to uh take it to the
next level for
season three but now we're up for it you
premiered last summer
at comic-con and then you had already
been filming season two you leave
comic-con to go back to set
and now people know what the show is so
what was it like actually filming on
location
after people now knew what the hell you
were
so now you're starting to see yourself
tagged in posts
um and you know you're you're trying to
be as discreet as possible but
you know you might see yourself tagged
in the post of a boys poster
you know when when our set decorators go
into a particular location
they'll put up you know uh paraphernalia
suit paraphernalia you know like at a
bodega they'll dress it up in like
a train power bars and you know
starlight
you know chains and things like that so
now when people see it
they'll start they'll start uh posting
it and obviously you know you don't want
to give away any secrets and you don't
want
things to get leaked before you can you
can share it the right way
but outside of that man i mean you know
we shoot in toronto
it's an amazing city to film we have
some of the best crew members um
uh just everyone there they're
professionals
on on every single scale of
of of the crew and and and the the
background work they're they're
they're really they're dialed in so
uh i think we're a really good good city
to work in man i mean you have anything
that you you can add to that carl like
yeah i i guess what i experienced was
general appreciation for the show um you
know it's always nice
uh when um fans of the show come up and
and and uh express their appreciation
you know it's not like you know as
actors when you
do theater or something you get a pretty
solid indication pretty immediately
whether what you've done or not is
appreciated and
um you know we've just got we've got the
best fans and i'm grateful
for the fact that uh well we get to go
for uh for round three and
um yeah so it's all good yeah
yeah i have a million other questions
but i already have to wrap i'm just
gonna say i cannot wait to watch the
rest of season two
uh what i've seen so far is fantastic
thank you so much for your time
thank you